Вже місяць як електрозварювальник Юрій виконує не типову роботу
на кожному поверсі тернопільських багатоповерхівок завар ює сміттєпроводи.
Заварив їх для того щоб, винести мусор, мусорокамери, на вулицю і щоб сортувати сміття.
Працює не лише під шум зварювальної машини, але й часто під критику мешканців.
Старенька людина, якщо ліфт не працює, з десятого поверху, ось як я мешкаю, не може винести його.
Вона розізлиться і возьме, і викине через вікно.
Тому що зійти людині дуже тяжко.
Втім, пенсіонеру Сергію доведеться звикати.
Міськрада Тернополя взялась за реалізацію закону України "Про відходи".
Перший крок - ліквідація сміттєпроводів.
Наступний - облаштування сміттєвих майданчиків у кожному дворі.
Зробити це до першого червня мають управителі будинків чи ОСББ - власним коштом.
Щоб можна було окремо сортувати скло, органіку і пластик_
міськрада Тернополя зобов’язала компанії, що займаються вивезенням сміття,
власним коштом укомплектувати сміттєві майданчики додатковими баками.
Підприємство Богдана Гевка вже закупило для збору скла 60 вживаних контейнерів з Європи.
Кожен по 150 євро. Протягом наступних трьох місяців повинен докупити ще 200 баків.
Щоб вистачило на усі райони, які він обслуговує.
Але що робити зі зібраною сировиною - поки не знає.
Наразі шукає способи реалізації та прораховує рівень прибутків,
який повинен компенсувати підприємству несподівані витрати.
Тобто умовно, якщо ми за кілограм несортованого скла беремо 70 копійок,
за відсортоване можна брати 1,20 грн.
Але тут всьо будемо пробувати, це для нас нове,
чи буде резон сортувати - подивимось.
Треба людей, територію велику, приміщення.
Тим часом в Тернополі діє доволі успішне приватне підприємство,
яке вже понад вісім років збирає скляні пляшки, склобій та бляшанки.
Скляну тару повертають назад на заводи.
А потім та знову опиняється на полицях магазинів.
Бляшанки - на Київський алюмінієвий завод.
Про те, що місто планує зобов’язати усіх сортувати скло, на бізнесмен Роман не чув.
Поки ще жодне з трьох тернопільських підприємств, що мають забезпечити сортування скла,
до нього не зверталось.
Втім, конкурентів не боїться - ввжає, що реформа тільки пожвавить його бізнес.
Адже розвине культуру сортування.
Я думаю, що вигідно було б, бо більша кількість була.
Багато пляшок і склобою викидається в смітники і потім неможливо їх звідти витягнути,
закопується в землю, але якщо б окремо сортувалось,
то, зрозуміло, що більше б поверталось на вторинну переробку.
Сортувати, хоч і на мінімальному рівні, тернополяни вже навчені.
Принаймні пластикову пляшку тут збирають з 2013 року.
За роки об’єми накопичення сировини зросли удвічі.
Нині щороку йдеться про 100 тонн пластику, які інакше опинились би просто на сміттєзвалищі.
Натомість, ось така пляшка отримує друге життя на заводах Львова, Києва, Фастова та Харкова.
Деякі заводи: дехто переробляє на ту ж саму пляшку, тобто робить преформу,
з якої та сама пляшка виходить. А дехто на волокно.
Це ті ж самі спортивні костюми, виготовляють фактично синтетичний одяг - з того матеріалу йде.
Але тільки на склі та пластику влада Тернополя обіцяє не зупинятися.
І готує проект з відкриття сортувальної станції біля сміттєзвалища.
Там хочуть досортовувати відходи, наприклад, відбирати метал та інші цінні матеріали.
З-поміж планів - і налагодити сортування паперу.
На нього з нетерпінням чекає той же Київський картонно-паперовий завод.
Але успішність реалізації реформи залежить і від містян, кажуть у мерії.
Поки ж тернополяни, попри наявність контейнерів для пластику,
продовжують кидати пляшки у загальні відходи.
Тим більше тару не завжди стискають і миють.
Водночас коштів на інформаційну кампанію щодо правильного сортування,
чиновники виділяти не планують.